vous êtes un rocker maintenant je sais
pas c'est une rockstar on va faire un
test
le rockstar test est ce que vous êtes né
dans la rue je peux enfin je sais pas
j'ai pas de souvenirs c'est cela un
souvenir très bien est ce que vous êtes
déjà battu pendant un nouveau concert
battu way we are et c'était le gant
c'était en corse à bastia et les mac ou
de la tène personnage heures non c'est
vrai elle est bonne et son saxo et
enfonce à l'aréna avec 12 heures avec
l'organisateur vous voulez pas ventilé
la boiteuse sociaux avec les pieds
dedans
non ils voulaient pas me donner des
leçons aux autres il disait que mariano
chantait sans micro guêpe à volants
ouais bon vieux murs peints au plus bas
est-ce que vous avez déjà couché avec
votre cousine
non jamais non mais non il a fait lui
oui mais je joue pas de piano non plus
demain c'est vrai est ce que vous êtes
déjà mort dans un accident d'avion non
ci rappelle toi
la réponse est non et lance un pass 1 je
le prends en 2g est-ce que vous avez
déjà saccagé une chambre d'hôtel oui à
l'appui c'est à côté une fois est-ce que
vous avez déjà fait une overdose au
palace non non vous ai déjà chanté du
charles trenet quoi que reste-t-il de
nos amours la mer entre autres est-ce
que vous avez déjà chanté avec maurice
chevalier
ouais c'est mauvais ça pour être ocstat
ah bon ouais il a coulé on n'en entend
plus parler
ça fait du bien le twist du canotier 1
est-ce que vous avez déjà été inquiété
pour des problèmes de drogue dans un
aéroport américain
je suis mauvais temps mauvais vous
n'êtes pas est un rockeur zettel
rockstar ah bon vous avez déjà demandé à
obispo de pas vous composer des chansons
c'est pas gentil je m excuse et quelque
chose en nous de tennessee regarde
regarde non mais enfin ça c'est paris
quand on l'a quand on connaît les
tendances sexuelles de tennessee
williams double pas d'accord bonne
réponse vous ai déjà été agressé par un
fan on ne te ment pas non pas comme les
nan qua non encore un dont on n'entend
plus parler dit elle c'est parce qu'il
faut j'ai déjà allé sur le plateau de la
star academy pour faire de la promo oui
deux fois oui
non moi moi je vérifie ah non mais
attendez ça paye mieux qui suit
bien on y va et d excuse a été de boire
ou de fumer non plus ça c'est bien non
et pour être star c'est bien a bon les
excès il faut faire beaucoup d'excès abo
j'avance eu beaucoup de boulot vous vous
jetez dans votre public à la fin d'un
concert
michel si des peines
arrête avec ce mot photo bela messieurs
j'accueille